M1: This really has to be seen
to be believed, and I believe
you will believe it momentarily. I told you
yesterday how Republicans and Donald Trump are now
very aggressively demanding credit for
the coronavirus vaccines, which they said
we didn't really need to end the pandemic and
that the pandemic wasn't really serious anyway,
and which many of them are refusing to take. That
vaccine is the one they now want credit for. Well,
there's now layer two of this, which is that
there are now many Republican lawmakers who voted
against the recent one point nine dollars billion
covid stimulus bill that was recently passed by
Democrats exclusively and Democrats alone who want
to take credit for it, Republicans who want to
take credit for it. Let's look at some examples.
F3: Here is Republican Congresswoman Maria Salazar
tweeting over the weekend, quote, So proud
to announce that the Biden administration
has just implemented my bipartisan covid relief
bill as part of small business, part of Small
Business Administration policy. She voted
against it. She didn't vote for it, and now
she wants credit for it. And there are so many
of these. Republican senator from Mississippi,
Roger Wicker, did the exact same thing, tweeting
how glad he is that, quote, Independent restaurant
operators have won twenty eight billion dollars
worth of targeted relief. He's cheering that
quote, This funding will ensure small businesses
can survive the pandemic by helping to adapt
their operations and keep their employees on the
payroll. But he voted against the bill and now he
wants credit for it and he's bragging about it.
And apparently he's going to campaign on this.
Republican Congressman Adam Kinzinger tweeted
that, quote, We owe it to the American people
to work together in doing everything we can to get
them the covid relief they need. Bipartisanship is
critical in effective legislating, except he voted
against it and there was no bipartisanship despite
significant Republican support for the covid
relief bill. And then in a statement that Adam
Kinzinger links to, he actually says today, I'm
glad to know my constituents will be receiving
an additional relief payment and funding
to help improve their access to vaccines,
PPY and unemployment insurance. But he voted
against it. And in the statement, he adds,
But the legislation passed today is one of
the largest expenditures in American history,
with spending unrelated to the covid-19 pandemic
and Republicans were left out of all negotiations.
Now, it's untrue that Republicans were left
out of all negotiations. We've already talked
about this bullet point that's floating around
saying 91 percent of the money wasn't for covid
wasn't actually covid relief. Well, that depends
on how you define it. And much of it is for
infrastructure affected by coronavirus public
transit affected by coronavirus when people aren't
riding public transit. Korona Public transit
infrastructure deteriorates and then we come out
of the pandemic with even even crappier, for lack
of a better term, public transit infrastructure,
which the US already doesn't do particularly
well. And so we did all this debunking already,
but still he wants credit, even though he voted
against it. Radical extremist Kuhnen Congresswoman
Lauren Bobert defiantly tweeting that, hell
yes, you should be getting the money. Why
it's your money after all that you already paid
into the government in taxes saying, quote,
The framing of stimulus checks is all wrong. This
is not fourteen hundred dollars being given to you
by your generous government. This is money that
you and your fellow countrymen already paid into
the system. So if she thinks it's taxpayer money
that should go back to taxpayers, why did she
vote against the money going back to taxpayers?
How can Republicans who voted against the bill
take credit for the bill? And sadly, part of the
answer is if their own constituents are ignorant
enough to fall for it. And it appears that many
are. I mean, after all, they're the same people
that voted for Donald Trump. If they're if they're
dumb enough to fall for it, why not go with it?
And thus these Republicans are setting themselves
up to when it's convenient, say I refused the pork
of the covid stimulus, but talking out of the
other side of their mouths, they can also say,
I am so glad that the Congress I was a part of
delivered money to my. Constituents, they're
going to try to play both sides and in a way, it's
kind of simpler for us that they all voted against
it. And what I mean by that is, like if some
Republicans had voted for the covid relief bill,
we would have to say, OK, let's see, Rand Paul
is trying to take credit for the bill. We have
to check. Did Rand vote for it or did Rand vote
against it? They all voted against it, every
single one of them. So if they have an R next to
their name between now and 2022, you know, they
voted against the bill and we can save ourselves
the time of having to actually look it up